ciao a tutti
è un tema secondo me questo della
velocità delle due velocita molto
interessante del motivo per cui sono
venuto qua volentieri io sono diciamo
nato veloce sono una persona che è
portata per la velocità e ho fatto
sempre le cose prima o sbagliato prima
sono cresciuto prima sono lì mi sono
rimesso in piedi prima quindi sono
sempre stato molto veloce ma proprio
perché sono veloce ho apprezzato molto
anche la lentezza quindi il mondo se
com'è non è a due velocità il mondo è
attentissimo e velocità e è veramente
impressionante per me che viaggio molto
sia per lavoro e per piacere notare ogni
volta come le velocità possono essere
estremamente differenti e in ogni
velocità di come si fanno le cose ci
possono essere comunque delle cose
valide fini non c'è una ricetta vincente
quello che secondo me è la vera
differenza è quanto una persona è
connessa connessa a quello che succede
poi uno può essere connesso con dei
tempi
diciamo lenti tranquilli o può essere
connesse fare tutto velocissimo però
veramente le persone che rimangono un po
fuori immaginato sono quelle che non si
accorgono di quello che sta succedendo
faccio alcuni esempi su questo
soprattutto sulla velocità io diciamo
viaggio tra posti e stranamente diversi
perché vivo a lugano che direi che una
cittá lenta lavoro a diciamo tra chiasso
milano londra parigi diciamo oggi giro
per l'europa
e ogni volta che cambio posto ieri da
londra e vedi le cose va e le conferenze
incontri le gente perché ti sembra che
il tipo di velocità sia dieci volte
superiore al resto
poi però questo crea in tantissime
persone una enorme
l'anno scorso sono stato per esempio del
forse del posto in questo momento che
più veloce al mondo che è la california
a frequentare rivedere tutti i vari
colleghi di google facebook terra e
tutte queste aziende di questo tipo è la
cosa che mi ha stupito di più
quanta ansia c'era in tante persone
molto arrivate che avevano che avevano
veramente delle cose interessanti e
fatte le cose interessanti la vita ma
poi sono hanno sempre l'ansia loro che
sono lì in california nella silicon
valley hanno l'ansia di essere di
rimanere indietro mentre invece poi una
mia terza dimensione è quella di essere
un produttore di vino e olio nelle
marche e nel centro italia dove
veramente la velocità è infinitamente
inferiore da quelle altre avevo detto
dove la gente è totalmente diversa però
in cui trovi e incontri delle persone
che hanno dei ritmi di vita nel modo di
pensare che sono molto interessanti
tutto ciò per dire cosa che non esiste
secondo me la velocità giusta
io per esempio che ho vissuto tutto
molto velocemente nel mio primo pezzo di
vita nel senso che mi sono laureato come
primo del politecnico di milano a luglio
del quinto anno prima volta quando ho
fatto il corso di religione gestionale
sono andato a lavorare in mckinsey sono
stato il più giovane che era stato
promosso e tutte queste cose qua a 29
anni ho staccato tutto sono andato per
18 mesi in giro in barca a vela
quindi sono passato dalla massima della
velocità un mondo che 29 anni avevo più
o meno visto e non mi interessava
particolarmente andare avanti in quel
modo e ho cambiato totalmente ho
comprato una barca con mia moglie siamo
andati in viaggio di nozze e siamo
partiti per un'avventura totalmente
diversa che poi ha cambiato totalmente
la mia vita perché poi da quello ho
iniziato a lavorare nei viaggi e mandato
diciamo esplorare una cosa diversa e
quindi anche il cambiare velocità è
comunque molto utile perché ti fa avere
una prospettiva diversa
che cos'è secondo me la cosa
fondamentale il comun denominatore è
quello di riuscire a capire a qualsiasi
velocità che cosa succede intorno a
capire che cos'è mondo e il grosso
vantaggio degli ultimi anni è quello che
comunque
e accessibile a tutti sapere quello che
succede perché ovviamente c'è internet
social network sono the vix ci sono
tante cose per cui chiunque anche
vivendo nel paesino più remoto della
terra o in mezzo a una campagna nel
centro italia nel sud italia sia la
testa attiva o comunque cercare di
capire quali sono i trend anche se non
li vive tutti i giorni e questo è un
vantaggio enorme della nostra epoca
quello che dico è quello che tutti alle
volte ci si chiede dice ma come si fa
poi a capire e viaggiare nel futuro cioè
capire che cosa succederà io dico questo
che nella capire i macro trend
se come è molto facile capire questi
macro trend che da che cosa porteranno o
che cosa bisogna fare per aver successo
per seguire merenda è molto difficile se
noi andiamo a dire cosa avremmo previsto
20 anni fa venti anni fa era chiarissimo
che il mondo sarebbe cambiato grazie a
internet
io che avevo una piccola agenzia di
viaggi mi sono reso conto che avevo un
piccolo sito web messo su nel 96 che tra
l'altro esiste ancora sia un male lo so
che spunti per che vendevo vacanze in
barca a vela appunto dopo aver fatto
questa esperienza in un piccolo
arcipelago in venezuela mi sono accorto
dell'importanza di internet e da lì ho
sempre lavorato su quello quindi
alla fine non penso a posteriori fosse
molto difficile capire che definì anni
90 internet aveva cambiato il mondo
il problema avere il coraggio di
esplorare di andare in qualcosa di nuovo
se avessero detto cinque anni fa
che cos'era che cambiava il mondo il
mondo è cambiato e cambierà e sta
cambiando dal marketing personalizzato
noi stessi su internet facciamo un
marketing molto massa quindi a tutti più
o meno lo stesso lo stesso informazione
oggi come oggi
oggi sulla diciamo su tutti i giornali
questo scandalo facebook è quello che
tutti noi del settore sappiamo benissimo
che il messaggio deve essere quanto anni
questa è stata una rivoluzione enorme
sarà una decorazione norme se devo dire
che cos'è che cambierà il mondo dei
prossimi dieci anni
e chiarissimo a tutti quelli che
guardano un po e la blow c'entra produce
sarà una rivoluzione pazzesca uguale a
quella di internet tanta gente dice che
nella catena di sant'antonio neanche
capito dove dove sono e come andrà a
cambiare il mondo
diciamo tornando al tema della velocità
che mi sembra molto carino e alla fin
fine che cosa che cos'è la motivazione
perché uno deve essere veloce o deve
essere lento può essere più connesso
vino connesso secondo me è la
motivazione la curiosità e la voglia di
esplorare cioè quello che ci permette di
avere diciamo una testa veloce uno dei
temi che mi hanno detto oggi venendo qua
era ma abbiamo scelto legnano perché
legnano è più lento di milano è un po
isolato come come cosa vuol dire in una
provincia far qualcosa io quello che
dico è che tutto la curiosità la
curiosità e l'esplorazione la
motivazione che ci deve alzare tutti
almeno a me personalmente è quello che
mi fa alzare la mattina per cercare di
vedere qualcosa di nuovo e quindi a quel
punto sei uno stimolo vuoi essere veloce
e cercare di farlo
il mondo che abbiamo davanti secondo me
è un mondo se non la prende in questo
senso molto affascinante per qualcuno
che ha questa mentalità io da quando
sono bambino volevo fare quando ero
bambino volevo fare l'esploratore
io penso che l'esploratore sia a me è
quello che mi muove mi fa andare veloce
alzare la mattina esplorare nuovi mondi
le spirali nuovi mondi l'ho fatto in
senso fisico nel senso che ho girato il
mondo anche con la mia barca a vela per
scoprire e vedere avere delle esperienze
ma soprattutto lo si deve fare in modo
mentale l'esploratore che cos'è
l'esploratore a una persona che gira che
viaggia senza mappa senza mappa perché
per definizione
se vado in un posto nuovo non posso
sapere che cosa che cosa c'è e
l'esploratore dei tempi moderni tutti
secondo me siamo esploratori perché noi
siamo in un mondo che non sappiamo cosa
succederà fra 5 10 anni
tutto è molto più veloce di come era
prima tutte le i cambiamenti sono sempre
più veloci di come sono stati e quindi
l'unico modo e attrezzarsi di riuscire a
viaggiare senza ma ma perché nessuno ci
può dire la ricetta di cos'è il futuro e
come fa uno viaggiare senza mappa per
viaggiare senza mappa devi fare degli
errori deve andare tentativi devi
imparare dagli errori e quindi è
arricchirsi con le proprie esperienze
con le palle le proprie i propri bimbi
che si sono sbagliati e il mondo
secondo me nel mondo ricevono più
attrezzati a vivere in questo mondo
quelle persone che hanno un'anima
esplorativa e non devono avere una mappa
che è una regola un qualcosa e qualcuno
che dice questo deve fare ma devono
sperimentare allora chi sperimenta
viaggio con la mente e guarda nuovi
territori
sicuramente anche se vive in un posto
diciamo un pochettino più indietro potrà
sicuramente essere anche più veloce nel
fare raggiungere anche gli altri
su questo quindi il cambiamento come
detto è molto veloce quindi l'unico modo
per poter stare dietro è continuare a
essere dentro al cambiamento e non e non
subirlo faccio tre esempi di cose che
diciamo
ho fatto ultimamente possono essere
utili per capire che cosa c'è bisogno in
questo mondo che cambia veloce molto
velocemente
la prima cosa è per esempio per chiunque
a un'azienda che a che fare con dei
clienti o comunque chiunque si vuole
interfacciare con delle altre persone
essere rilevante per gli altri noi siamo
un mondo in cui siamo bombardati di
informazioni bombardati di esperienze
bombardati di stimoli l'unico modo in
cui noi diciamo a connetterci con
qualcuno con un cliente con un amico con
una donna che vogliamo conquistare è
essere rilevanti e quindi tutto della
vita e cercare di riuscire a diciamo
fare filtro e cercare di capire che cosa
rilevante quindi focalizzarsi in un
mondo molto complesso sulle cose che
fanno la differenza e questo quindi è
quello che io personalmente diciamo con
le varie attività che faccio una delle
mie attività principale ancora vendere
viaggi con questo gruppo che si chiama
lastminute.com troviamo 1.200 dipendenti
vediamo viaggi per 2 miliardi e mezzo è
quello di cercare di appunto essere
rilevante per i nostri clienti
l'altro discorso che abbiamo fatto io
cerco di applicare quello che penso a
comunque le mie aziende le mie
iniziative abbiamo siamo nati
acquistando abbiamo fatto questa nuova
campagna sul ne abbiamo il colore rosa
come motto che fanti usiamo magenta sia
come last minute nel utilizzato anche la
nuova iniziativa che si chiama virus di
cui vi parlo fra un attimo una cosa
molto interessante che abbiamo
analizzato per capire è che noi siamo
quello che assimiliamo e questo è una
cosa fondamentale nella vita e torno con
il tema anche della velocità della
conoscenza alla fin fine nessuno nasce
imparato chiunque di noi è quello che ha
fatto con le esperienze che ha fatto la
somma delle persone che ha incontrato
delle cose che ha visto un esempio che
mi ha interessato per quello che fate
la campagna in questo momento è quello
dei fenicotteri fenicotteri sono rosa i
fenicotteri sono rosa perché non nascono
rosa diventano rosa perché perché
mangiano i gamberetti che sono rosa e
che la cosa che mi piace più fare quindi
suggerimento e su questo per stare
impari perché la velocità vuol dire
stare in paris è se uno fa con curiosità
esplora le cose che gli piacciono
assimila talmente queste cose che
diventa lui stesso il suo mondo il mondo
di ciascuno di noi e tutto quello che
noi assimilavano il cibo di fi chiamo
giorno dopo giorno con quello che
facciamo e questo è assolutamente io se
una persona diciamo curiosa mi piace
fare cose nuove e quindi vedo che dopo
piano piano assimilando nuove esperienze
cambiamo anche noi stessi e uso gli
ultimi cinque minuti per far alavi della
mia ultima esperienza che quella
ovviamente in questo momento mi sta più
a cuore anche perché se mai si esprime
molto il concetto della velocità di
avere tutti di tutti insieme io che ho
fatto tutt'altro nella vita perché ho
fatto ingegnere consulente imprenditore
e il businessman diciamo detta così
l'anno scorso in meno di un anno fa ho
avuto questa pazza idea di diventare
anche un autore creatore di un format e
produttore televisivo e è perché l'ho
fatto questo perché mi sono reso conto e
scusa mi sono inventato per chi non lo
conoscesse questa nuova iniziativa che
si chiama binchi rosa perché si chiama
così è perché l'ho fatta si chiama così
perché io penso che sia molto importante
aiutare gli imprenditori a tre sono
stati un imprenditore ha avuto la
fortuna di girare il mondo
vedo che ci sono tantissimi imprenditori
in italia italia è il paese degli
imprenditori non sempre gli imprenditori
ricevono gli stimoli e gli aiuti giusti
che ci possono essere per potere presa
e sono stato inverso questo tutto in
italia degli eroi gli imprenditori per
sé sono quelli che si caricano sulle
spalle il peso di fare qualcosa
rischiando del mettendosi in gioco se
stessi totalmente se stessi e questo il
motivo per cui questa iniziativa
l'abbiamo chiamata billy ras che cos'è
vichi e la spears è un progetto in cui
abbiamo coinvolto i migliori
imprenditori italiani mostrano va sul
nostro sito vede la lista di centinaia
di imprenditori caduto successo hanno
fatto cose buone nella vita nella
aiutare i giovani imprenditori il
concetto americano diciamo degli back
cioè di riuscire a fare è aiutare in
quello che si conosce chiaramente io
conosco questa cosa è più facile per me
aiutare un imprenditore che cosa vuole
una scuola in africa che una cosa molto
lodevole ma di lui non c'è la minima
idea e quindi cosa abbiamo fatto con
questo progetto abbiamo cercato di
selezionare le migliori aziende giovani
e aziende italiane le cosiddette start
up siamo partiti da 650 abbiamo fatto un
tour in italia ne abbiamo visti circa
250 ne abbiamo selezionate al 32 su
queste 32 abbiamo investito per cercare
di far sì che queste 32 aziende abbiano
successo per fare sì cui di questa cosa
che cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo fatto da
una parte mi ha cercato di prendere come
detto le 32 migliori
abbiamo preso circa 100 imprenditori
italiani li abbiamo messi insieme
quindi abbiamo creato connessione e per
aiutare questi a crescere e perché
connessione proprio per il tema delle
velocità c'è una start up che sta
berlino a londra o in silicon valley è
già connessi a tutti vede tutti non c'è
bisogno di niente una start up che sta a
palermo a reggio calabria o disperse
qualsiasi borsa del nord italia all
bergamo como come ne abbiamo alcune ha
più difficoltà di avere tutte le
informazioni che gli servono tutti gli
aiuti che gli servono e quindi avevo
detto cerchiamo di creare anche in
italia una connessione tra le aziende in
modo che gli imprenditori più anziani
gli imprenditori più giovani e quelli
emergenti si aiutano tra di loro per
cercare di creare delle delle aziende
valide in più oltre ciò abbiamo detto va
bene ci sono tante aziende validissimi
d'italia e quindi abbiamo preso le più
grandi aziende diciamo del mondo
digitale quindi google facebook hamas
e tante altre tutte le più grandi
microsoft così che hanno dato dei
servizi gratuiti alle nostre start up
che abbiamo selezionato e quindi in
questo processo è iniziato il 18 gennaio
che uscirà a fine maggio
stiamo mettendo insieme queste di 32
aziende che abbiamo poi selezionato a 12
e li stiamo aiutando per cercare di
tirar fuori dei campioni nazionali e poi
tra questi 12 ne sceglieremo una in cui
investiremo 500mila euro 93 100 in
guerra o banca intesa che il partner in
questa iniziativa per aiutare
ulteriormente a crescere tutto questo
processo che io trovo molto interessante
con l'obiettivo primario è quello di
creare aziende valide
c'è un open divo si può andare se non è
molto importante che è quello di far
capire un obiettivo culturale in italia
quando si parla di start up tutti
pensano subito quanti soldi per vera
quando fallirà in america quando si
parla di start up tutti pensano google
facebook e company e pensano a quanti
soldi faranno quindi culturalmente
dobbiamo far capire ai giovani che c'è
uno sbocco enorme tutta l'innovazione
futura dell'italia dipende delle start
up e questo è un fenomeno è
importantissimo che avrà un impatto
enorme per il futuro dell'italia
soprattutto per colmare questo io lo
chiamo digital divide cioè la differenza
di velocità nel digitale che c'è tra
l'italia e con i paesi del nord europa
e questo il motivo per cui da questo da
questo iniziativa abbiamo creato anche
per me è una cosa ignota nuova un format
televisivo che dovuto inventare da zero
perché nessuno mi ascoltava e ci
credevano e l'abbiamo fatto
siamo andati in onda di due settimane fa
due puntate abbiamo avuto successo siamo
canale 9 dopo crozza abbiamo superato
tutte le previsioni e con oltre 600.000
spettatori e quindi alla fine perché
l'abbiamo fatto per dare un messaggio
far capire a tutti che questo fenomeno
l'unico modo in possiamo colmare questo
gap è colmare il gap che c'è tra noi e
il resto del nord europa le nazioni più
avanzate
ho finito nel tempo perfetto e quindi vi
vi lascio grazie a tutti
[Applauso]